good morning Maureen and nerdfighters
and John this video comes to you and
three pieces of exciting news the first
piece of exciting news is that the
sequel to sweet scarlet is out which I
would have for you I would show it to
you right now if it was anywhere in
Missoula there are a lot of advantages
to living in a nice small college town
in the middle of nowhere but one of the
disadvantages is that we never get books
like I had to wait two weeks to get my
hands on Paper Towns so I have called my
local independent bookseller and he
assures me that it will be there on
Friday at which point I would be buying
it but if you haven't read the first
sweet scarlet then this is your chance
to do it I love this book it's great I'm
a big Maureen Johnson fan which is why
it's pretty cool that she's doing this
with us I'm worrying you can read the
first chapter of this online right now
now I'm gonna do a dramatic thing that
everyone seems to be doing these days
there is still a lot that needs to be
done for Haiti I know that it's no
longer a gigantic news story and that
the terribleness of it all is starting
to wear off
but this remains something that the
world needs to address the Harry Potter
Alliance which is a nonprofit
organization set up on the foundations
of the Harry Potter fan community is
doing something really freaking awesome
for Haiti they have got some of the most
amazing raffle prizes in history and you
can buy raffle tickets for Haiti all of
the money goes to Haiti these prizes
range from all of the Harry Potter books
signed and authorized by JK Rowling with
a note from her saying thank you for
helping Haiti - a guitar signed and used
by tom felton who is the guy who plays
Draco Malfoy which I bought three
tickets for that I hope I win a copy of
Deathly Hallows signed by the entire
cast of the movie sign books by Neil
Gaiman sign books by Terry Pratchett
sign books by John Green art work from
where the wild things are both John and
Maureen will write a short story about
the topic of your choosing if you win
the raffle this is something that I
probably can guarantee will never be
offered again they will write a 1000
words short story for you about whatever
you want it to be about if you win you
could make John Green write Twilight fan
fiction about how he wants to French
kiss Edward Cullen you could do that it
could be you Maureen is offering the
same prize and I mean she actually does
want to french kiss out for Colin so
that wouldn't be as interesting but I
haven't seen this amazing
gesture from John Maureen wanted it was
something similar so I have decided that
I am auctioning off a hit song and when
I say hit I mean small scale but hit you
can buy raffle tickets for my raffle and
if you win I will write a song about you
or whatever you want me to write the
song about but maybe probably about you
I will call you on the phone and we will
talk about what you want your song to be
about and then I will write the song and
then I will go into the studio and
record the song and then I will make a
music video for the song I'm serious I
want this to be a very good song and I
want it to be on my next album and it
could be about you if you go and buy
raffle tickets now here's the deal the
Harry Potter Alliance the Harry Potter
community and the nerdfighter community
together have already raised eighty six
thousand dollars which is enough to
charter two cargo planes to go all the
way to Haiti filled with aid supplies
now what we want to do is get to 105
thousand dollars so that we can get
three cargo planes and name them Ron
Harry and Hermione that's what we want
to do and we really hope that we can get
there so the very least go check out
this list there are so much unique never
gonna get it again kind of stuff on this
list it's so exciting
I'm so amazed at the power of these
communities thank you everyone for
helping the last exciting announcement
is that if you are in Indianapolis right
now you can go see John Green John will
be doing two events at the University of
Indianapolis this Monday one a four
o'clock and one at 7:30 and you are
invited to both so if you're in or
around Indianapolis go hang out with my
brother cuz I can't and I want to so you
should go do it Maureen I will see you
on Friday
dftba